we have finally climbed to the top of
the stack of the 30 story lines we are
watching for 2019 now it's been a long
time since the Cleveland Browns have
been number one in anything they are
number one on our list of story lines
we're watching can they live up to an
unprecedented degree of hype and
expectation really more than anything
that any Browns team has endured for the
20 years that the Browns have been back
in the NFL quick history lesson the
Cleveland Browns are now the Baltimore
Ravens the original Cleveland Browns now
I know they left the name and the colors
and the records behind but that
franchise moved to Baltimore in 1996 the
Browns ceased to exist they returned as
an expansion team in 1999 they've been
to the playoffs once in the last 20
years they haven't had a winning record
since 2007 last year even though
everybody was excited about what they
did they were still seven eight and one
this year all of a sudden people expect
the Browns thanks to the arrival of
Odell Beckham jr. plus other moves that
were made by GM John Dorsey to be a
great team to win the division to
contend for a Super Bowl berth and I'm
not saying they can't but one of the
biggest things are gonna have to do is
handle the expectations and deal with
the adversity the extra adversity that
comes from losing games right if you're
the Browns last year and you lose your
opener who cares
you're the Browns this year the Titans
are rolling into town and everybody
thinks the Browns are gonna roll the
Titans and the Titans are good enough to
beat anyone any place any time and I
kind of think the Titans are gonna win
that game I just have a gut feeling that
the Browns are going to be shocked to
see that teams like the Titans aren't
gonna say oh okay Browns it's your year
here you go the Browns are gonna have to
be ready to take it and I think it's
gonna be a great sign for the Browns if
they do win that game I don't think they
will so how do they deal with Owen one
and then they go on the road to the Jets
week to Monday Night Football if they
lose that one a fall - Owen - how will
they handle adversity that's gonna be
the real question adversity will come at
some point and I think Baker Mayfield is
already skilled beyond his years at
getting his team focused and getting his
team motivated at getting his team ready
to do everything they need to do but my
big question is Freddie kitchens the
head coach of the team and I love
Freddie kitchens we interviewed him at
the league meetings
I think he's a great guy and I think
he's got the potential to lead the
Browns to a special place but a year ago
you know somebody had said to me hey why
don't you list from 1 to 100 the guys
out there that you think are viable
candidates to be head coaches in the NFL
next year I wouldn't book for any
kitchens on that list of 1 to 100 so
look at how the world has changed for
him in just one year can he step up into
this job maybe he can we've seen plenty
of successful assistant coaches fail to
thrive as head coaches this is a guy who
had success for a limited period of time
last year as the interim offensive
coordinator and he parlayed that into
the head coaching job can he get it done
that is going to be one of the biggest
factors in determining whether or not
the Cleveland Browns can live up to the
expectations that are being heaped upon
them by so many people and that's why
Freddie kitchens would like everyone to
just simmer down now with the
expectations and let it all play out
because the higher the expectations are
the harder it's going to be for kitchens
the harder it's going to be for the
Browns and 7 8 & 1 next year would be
viewed as a major disappointment over
last year's 7 8 & 1 that that literally
sparked a parade in Cleveland as it
relates to the excitement that it
brought to the team can they take it to
the next level we'll see biggest
storyline we're watching as 2019
approaches
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports